so you know pat brings up um
the tribute that adam sandler
ultimately what we're talking about is
chris's legacy and i mean
whether it's sandler's tribute whether
it's even you know comedians these days
theo vaughn his set you just had a
picture of farley on it yeah your
brother that's it that was his set
that's right and even you producing
our co-executive
co-executive producing uh i am farley
speaking of his legacy i mean
is it that's my brother or do you want
to kind of carve your own path how do
you balance being the brother of
literally
one of the greatest comedians to ever
live yeah i don't know you know i i have
to live with it so i don't try to like
separate it i talk a little bit about it
in my act you know and but like i say
i'm kind of chris farley light i don't
really jump around or do anything like
that all his comedy's a little different
than my comedy yeah
but i try not to run away from it i mean
i really can't i mean people that talk
to me all the time now when they know
that i'm chris's brother they want to
talk about it so i don't mind it of
course it's not something i run away
from but i yeah i'm trying to carve out
my own thing you know but i naturally
not as bombastic as him so not as loud
and gregor yeah but people want me to do
things like wow to that point speaking
of your bits not running away from it
you have got a great bit where you're
like
you know i'm the brother of a famous guy
and you kind of you talk about roger
clinton yeah there was a guy with other
brothers and other famous people or like
jim hanks that's a guy that came up to
me
i think it was bobby sladen that said
that to me and i think one time i just
laughed it was it was funny he goes
you're kevin farley yeah and he goes
yeah i know jim hanks
i'm like tommy what was that supposed to
mean
he knew jim had and he wasn't jim hanks
no no
this guy goes yeah i mean this is the
kind of conversations i always run yeah
you know i knew jimmy you're kev farley
yeah yeah and he goes yeah i know jim
hanks i'm like oh god okay
what is that supposed to be
you know so i'm like well this is the
kind of life that i have i'm like thanks
chris you know all right this is the
kind of thing these are the kind of
conversations i have with people you
know if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]